[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did your heart melt yet if not just give
it some time because jennifer lopez
bringing her 14 year old emmy muniz on
stage to perform a duet is a tear-jerker
for sure the duo sang a rendition of
christina perry's a thousand years
it's a beautiful moment jenny from the
black hit the stage with emmy at the los
angeles dodgers foundation blue diamond
gala marking their first time performing
together since the 2020 super bowl
halftime show and the last time we
performed together is in a big stadium
like this before emmy joined j.lo the 52
year old introduced them using they them
pronouns showing the world just how much
she respects emmy and i ask them to sing
with me all the time but they won't so
this is a very special occasion they're
very very busy
and booked
enticing they cost me when they come out
but they're worth every single penny
because they're my favorite
duet partner of all time
so if you would indulge me
and that we did when emmy appears on
stage they stand proudly holding a
bedazzled rainbow microphone dressed in
a fuchsia shirt and matching short set
and black dodgers baseball cap and kicks
off the duet with mom jlo
[Music]
what's that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow how special
[Music]
spreading the message of love on stage
seems like it might be a trend we can
continue to expect from these two back
in 2016 before emmy started performing
with their mom jennifer opened up to e.t
about how her children feel when she
includes tributes of them in her
performances and what she mentions about
emmy says it all
they love it they love it you know they
they go why is my face up there like my
son will be like why is my face up there
are people laughing at us like he gets
worried about that stuff and my
daughter's more like she just loves
watching it she just loves i don't know
she just watches me i don't know what
she's thinking yet i'm sure i'll know
soon